love it or leave it Suicide Squad
assured a ton of DC Comics aeneas
characters onto the big screen for the
first time and gave each one a makeover
in the bargain while some stayed closer
to the comic appearances than others
there were a few squad members who were
left completely transformed here's how
the Suicide Squad should really look
Captain Boomerang just like in the
comics Captain Boomerang is not really
an upstanding guy aesthetically though
the captain's live-action portrayal
diverges significantly from his original
form now there are probably no more
ridiculous outfits than his original
boomerang print tunic and tiny hat so
new boomerang is a welcome departure the
on-screen version is based more closely
on boomers modern costume so they both
wear a similar gray blue peacoat and
both have a knack for throwing
boomerangs which for the record are the
worst weapons of all time I can't
believe I said that as in Australia
oh no it's coming back this way back
throwing sticks stunner yours is
purmerend honor but Jai Courtney's
version has urbanized clothing and
jewelry his hair is not the orange of
his comics counterpart but he does
occasionally wear the knit cap Courtney
also extended the characters usual
sideburns into full of facial hair and
snuck in a little a makeup to boot El
Diablo
the fiery essence of chato Santana or el
Diablo was definitely not lost in
translation but there were still some
noticeable style changes with his ink in
the comics he has a swirl designs that
emphasizes his Flame theme with Jay
Hernandez in the live-action role the
characters skin art is changed to a
scattered slew of new symbols that paint
him as a true tough guy among his new
markings are hash marks on his eyebrows
and a skeletal teeth design featured on
his upper lip as well as a Grim Reaper
scythe on his forehead to show he's in
the business of death dealing even lost
on his journey of repentance katana
super arrow and katana has won multiple
costumes over her various TV appearances
but when she first appeared in the
comics in 1983 she had a red and yellow
costume with ridiculous pointed
shoulders and fur topped shoes you know
the least stealthy martial arts costume
possible over time she toned it down
into a red and gold armor deal with a
domino mask but it's katanas completely
revamped new 52 look that appeared on
screen Garen fuga horiz rendition of
katana still changes things up in a few
key ways her screen costume is a bit
more conservative than the skin tight
leotards katana wears in the comics
instead opting for a loose-fitting plain
t-shirt and pass she also doesn't have
traditional samurai shoulder guards
instead wearing a varsity style jacket
featuring floral tributes to a heritage
even with these changes katana is still
pretty recognizable Slipknot one of the
most significant design departures in
Suicide Squad can be found in Adam
Beach's version of
at night the movies costumes crew almost
totally dumped the characters comic
appearance a full muscle hugging
bodysuit with bizarre side windows loose
sleeves and a mask in the movie Slipknot
got a much more militaristic suit gone
was the corny nurse designer on his
chest instead he was decked out in
useful utility gear and a built-in
rappelling harness and his hair was tied
back to look like what else
ROK's can't said the guy doesn't have a
theme it's too bad he was only on screen
for about three minutes rick flagg Joel
Kinnaman interpretation of Rick Flagg is
relatively faithful to the modern
version of the character but there is
still a handful of small style changes
as a member of the US Army Special
Forces the comics version of Rick Flagg
keeps a close shave most of the time
whereas the movie version has a little
more going on under his nose Kinnaman is
also a living breathing human so he's a
little less beefy than the flag familiar
to DC readers however just like his
paper bound predecessor in the role
Kinnaman stake tended to wear the same
army green jumpsuit and battlefield
grade arms and of course the low guard
buzz cut that serves as a not-so-subtle
salute to his military service Amanda
Waller just as in the comics Amanda
Waller is the tough assembler of Task
Force X who in actress Viola Davis words
is a big powerful black woman hard and
ready to pick up a gun and shoot anyone
at will unlike many of the other
characters in Suicide Squad Davis's
version of Waller bypassed DC Comics
reboot new 52 renditions of her
character and went all the way back to a
earlier more business-oriented look like
in her 1980s legends debut her pearls
and hairdo for example were pretty close
replicas of some of the earliest
appearances the Joker while Jared Leto's
version of the Joker adopted some of the
comics versions physical characteristics
it was also a new take on the character
in several noticeable ways while Leto
did key
The Joker's bright green do he slicked
it down instead of the more unkempt
approach often favored by the classic
Joker Leto's Joker assured in the era of
the character with grilled teeth and
threatening tattoos and while we don't
get to see the Joker's bare back sad
photos and statues based on the movie
revealed a dragon tattoo that looks
pretty similar to the one Joker has in
all-star Batman and Robin even his
signature purple coat got a biker
friendly update rather than the playful
suit styling a bold he had a shiny
alligator skin number and went shirtless
beneath just in case people wanted to
see that he wrote his own name on his
stomach you know just in case you forgot
or just got lost in a mall Harley Quinn
margot robbie hit a home run as the bat
wielding harley quinn but the character
is hardly recognizable as the one that
debuted in Batman
the animated series the old Harley Quinn
looks like a straight-up jester which we
got to see on-screen during Suicide
Squad for one hot second
but it's the later versions of the
character that lent a great deal to
Harley's movie look Robbie is a
postmodern Punk complete with colourful
pigtails messy makeup tattoos and a
getup that should appeal to cheerleaders
and biker chicks alike the pigtails are
borrowed specifically from Harley's
appearance in the video game Batman
Arkham City and the tattered t-shirt is
pure injustice gods among us and we can
thank a new 52 solo title for those
shorts Killer Croc the appearance and
origin story of Killer Croc have changed
so many times over the years that
there's really not one true croc but the
guy we see in Suicide Squad is
surprisingly true to his very first full
appearance in Batman number 358 where
he's just a guy with this skin condition
during his first appearance he showed up
in a standard mobster trench coat and
hat and sambal in Suicide Squad he's
wearing a hoodie which is pretty much
the modern equivalent
one as time goes by in the comics Crocs
slowly devolves into a more brutish
animalistic villain sprouting a tail and
long reptilian snout so while the
cinematic counterpart seems to be a
relatively regular guy now the future
isn't looking too bright sorry dude
Deadshot it's hard to hide a face as
marketable as well Smith's so it's no
wonder the Suicide Squad version of
Deadshot doesn't often wear his
trademark mask when he does put it on
the on screen version flips the script
and places his fancy site over wills
left eye whereas comics Deadshot favors
the right it's a relatively small
difference compared to the big picture
however on screen he wears a uniform
that looks like riot gear and his usual
red and silver costume is nowhere to be
seen
also Floyd Lawton has traditionally been
a white guy with a doofy little mustache
honestly we prefer the fresh prints in
this instance all of this however is
light-years away from dead shots first
appearance in 1950 where he looked like
a stage magician top hat and all he
tangled with Batman once and disappeared
until 1977 when he took on his more
modern look which is still nothing like
what we see on screen enchantress in the
comics enchantress receives her powers
after wandering off into a creepy room
at a mansion party and talking to a fat
magichead in a giant chair because why
not
after blond Bob head June moon
transforms into enchantress she looks
like a standard sexy Halloween witch
brain pointed hat long cape miniskirt
and thigh high boots later as she loses
control of the palace and turns a little
evil she dons an emerald green halter
top and gold band fitted around her head
with occasional returns to her
old-school look in Suicide Squad
enchantress is an archaeologist who gets
her powers from an ancient relic
whatever got under her skin in that
creepy old temple also gave her a
complete gross makeover making a far
more darken
gee then a comics counterpart only
cleaning up a bit when her powers are at
full force the on screen inch at risk
played by Cara Delevingne wears a hunter
green swimsuit and Crescent headdress a
weird shadow of a comics counterpart and
for some reason the filmmakers decided
to make her look kind of like Pigpen
from Charlie Brown
good grief thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
costume upgrade you liked the most